We're crushing our coolest
videos into bite-sized pieces
for your inspiration and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson, and this
is King of Random Rewind.
10. BAT BLADES
9. MINI LONGBOW
8. SMOKE RING CANNON
7. CLOTHESPIN GUN
6. MOUSETRAP GUN
5. PEN BOW AND ARROW
4. CAP DARTS
3. MINI RPG LAUNCHER
2. OFFICE DARTS
1. MICRO CROSSBOW
Hey guys, grant here.
Hope you enjoyed this compilation.
If you'd like to see the full
tutorials for these videos,
We've got links down in the description.
If you'd like to
see another compilation,
click the box up there
And if you're not already subscribed,
go ahead and click the bomb.
We'll see you in the next video.
Talk to you then.